bonjour repris en aide à la merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france tout
d'abord avec quel est le degré
d'attentes des chiliens avec 7 avec
cette nouvelle constitution
et oui bonjour bah je pense que les
degrés d'attentes et est énorme dans les
sens où ce qui est en train de vivre les
chili est un vrai tsunami démocratique
suite à la révolte populaire qui a eu
lieu il ya deux ans quand tous les
signes alliés par pierre du 18 octobre
beijing 19 la précédente constitution
avait tété a rédigé un sous la dictature
d'augusto pinochet pourquoi avoir
attendu presque trente ans pour la
changer
c'est une bonne question les chili si
vous voulez les 50 dernières années
c'était au départ une révolution avec
l'élection du président socialiste
salvador allende que tout le monde de
regarder parce que c'était la première
fois qu'un un président à des gauche
arriver au pouvoir par les élections
ensuite nous avons eu 17 ans de
dictature justement du général pinochet
et à l'intérieur de ses 17 ans à partir
des années 80 il a eu il ya des réformes
économiques qui ont mis en place cette
nouvelle constitution et à partir de là
les trente dernières années de
démocratie depuis le départ de pinochet
ont été consacrés au développement d'un
système néolibéral à outrance qui a est
elle qui est un modèle mondial
donc c'est ce processus là
en faisant un grand raccourci il est
maintenant devant les élèves a été
devant les électeurs et ça a donné comme
résultat cette élection d'une nouvelle
assemblée constituante au chili alors là
les débuts de cette constitution vont
voir le jour aujourd'hui c'est
aujourd'hui qu'elle commence à être
écrite 755 citoyens vont participer
justement à l'écriture de cette nouvelle
constitution elle c'était important
justement de permettre aux citoyens
chiliens de décrire eux-mêmes cette
constitution et c'est un point
fondamental dans l'essence ou parmi les
155 constituants qui ont été élus
démocratiquement il ya un mois il ya 77
femmes et 70 hommes à l'intérieur des
cdc groupe des constituants qui sont
chargés de rédiger la nouvelle
constitution
il y à aussi 17 constituants qui font
partie des peuples originaires du chili
ce qui n'était jamais arrivé et c'est
pour ça aussi que cette constitution des
17 conventions constituante et est assez
unique unique dans le monde il n'y en a
pas deux constitutions convention
constitutive assemblée constituante qui
soit configurée de la sorte comme la
fesci est justement est ce que cette
constitution ou en tout cas la rédaction
dans un premier temps va pouvoir calmer
les tensions sociales qui règne
actuellement au chili alors
très bonne question parce qu'il faut
d'un côté c'est réjouir qu' à partir de
d'aujourd'hui la convention constituante
commença sa première réunion officielle
et d'un autre côté il faut savoir que
dans quelques heures concert a débuté au
chili il y a quand même quatre
manifestations qui ont été appelés par
différents mouvements qui font partie
des constituants qui vont être à
l'intérieur du congrès santiago pour
réclamer les la liberté des personnes
qui ont été et qui sont encore en prison
à cause de la révolution sociale qui a
eu lieu il ya deux ans et il faut pas
oublier qu'elle est coût social pour
arriver à fêter c'est énorme avancée et
est énorme puisque plus des 400
personnes ont perdu un oeil me suis dit
en des comptes où 400 personnes
il ya encore des personnes qui sont
complètement
un homme jugé dans les prisons ou chili
et et puis ça ouverte ou sas a ouvert la
possibilité que des gens comme vous et
moi puissions être élu pour aller
proposer une nouvelle constitution en
paix pour hervé lane à la prochaine
élection présidentielle au chili aura
lieu le 21 novembre prochain est ce que
justement à cette nouvelle constitution
pour éventuellement changer quelque
chose quant à l'élection du prochain
président bah non c'est légalement non
dans l'essence ou la quantité du les
constituants sont pas là pour dire si
chili de changer deux des régimes
présidentiels et passer à autre chose ou
pas dont l'élection présidentielle aura
lieu il y aura un président élu et ses
présidents élus dans son mandat puisque
les mandats dure quatre ans au chili
aura à faire avec la nouvelle
constitution
si les projets de cette nouvelle
constitution et et ready et ratifié
puisque on a là bas après les neuf mois
des discussions et de rédaction plus
trois mois supplémentaires
éventuellement 7,7 ce texte sera soumis
à un référendum des sorties merci aurait
la main d'avoir été avec nous ce matin
sur rtl france rappelle que vous êtes sa
fondateur du blog
france chili merci beaucoup